how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there is a ton of talk about the footage
that was shown by Marvel and Disney at
CinemaCon yesterday now on Friday Marvel
and Disney on their own lot in Burbank
California showed footage of Avengers in
game that has never been seen before if
you missed that you can check out the
video I did on that in the link above
but yesterday Marvel and Disney showed a
sizzle reel at CinemaCon that had
footage of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in
it I've been getting a ton of questions
about this so I'll break it all down in
this video but first if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe i do
monthly giveaways right now i'm giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a painting of Thanos by globe I bow if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so like I
said yesterday Disney and Marvel showed
a sizzle reel that had footage of
Wolverine in it at CinemaCon what they
showed was Wolverine kind of talking to
Black Panther it shows Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine saying what is this place and
then it cuts to Wakanda and black
panther listening now a lot of people
are taking this out of context this does
not mean that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
is going to be an Avengers end game what
was shown was a sizzle reel and what a
sizzle reel is is a combination of a
bunch of different visuals put into a
video to kind of show an overview of
what a company is about and what they
can do so this isn't new footage that
was shot it was an old scene from an old
Wolverine film of him saying what is
this place and then it was a scene taken
from black panther but they cut the
footage in a way that made it seem like
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine was talking to
jacala so basically what this was was
Disney and Marvel going hey guess what
we have the x-men now and they're going
in the MCU and are going to be able to
interact with the current heroes that we
know and love now they could however be
specifically teasing Wolverine entering
the MCU and going to Wakanda
because Wakanda has most of if not all
of the vibranium in the world and Adam
in tiem which is the metal that is
inside of Wolverine is very similar to
vibranium so this could be Marvel and
Disney teasing us saying that we could
see Wolverine in whoa
talking to Black Panther fairly soon in
the future since Marvel owns the x-men
now but this does not mean that
Wolverine is going to appear in Avengers
in game I've been hearing a lot of
people say that that is not what this
means but Disney did show Wolverine in a
video with the Avengers and black
panther because the x-men are coming
into the MCU very soon so it is really
exciting so let me know what you think
about this sizzle reel that was shown by
Marvel and Disney at CinemaCon in the
comments down below and let me know how
excited you are to see the x-men finally
enter the MCU and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]